We know--everyone's finishing out October
with a Stranger Things binge.
But once those final credits roll, how will
you fill that Upside-Down-shaped hole in your
heart?
With more TV, of course!
November is bringing plenty of new movies
and shows to get excited about.
Here's everything coming to Netflix in November
2017, starting with the Netflix originals.
Alias Grace: Season 1
Hulu may have snagged The Handmaid's Tale,
but Netflix is fighting back with Alias Grace,
another drama series based on the works of
author Margaret Atwood.
Grace is the semi-biographical tale of Grace
Marks, a girl who was convicted of murdering
two people in 1843.
The Netflix adaptation stars Sarah Gadon as
the title character and will be released as
a six-part miniseries on November 3rd.
The Big Family Cooking Showdown: Season 1
Get ready for a mouth-watering good time with
this unscripted cooking face-off.
Each episode of The Big Family Cooking Showdown
sees two families go head to head to prepare
the best dish in a series of challenges.
Netflix got distribution rights for this popular
BBC Two cooking show, which originally aired
in the UK in August 2017.
Stream all of Season 1 on November 3rd.
Fate/Apocrypha: Part 1
Based on the series of light novels of the
same name, Fate/Apocrypha is an all-new anime
series that follows two warring clans, the
Red Faction and the Black Faction, at the
outbreak of an epic magical war.
Netflix and A-1 Pictures originally aired
the series exclusively in Japan in July 2017,
and they're bringing the dueling mages stateside
on November 7th.
If you're an anime fan, this is one new series
you can't miss.
The Killer
Netflix is extending their international acquisitions
this month with The Killer, a Brazilian crime
thriller that looks just as intense as its
name would suggest.
The story centers on a man named Shaggy who's
on a one-gun mission to track down a notorious
outlaw.
Netflix hasn't released many details about
this film, but The Killer looks like the Portuguese
spaghetti Western we've all been waiting for.
And we didn't even know it!
Check it out when it hits Netflix on November
10th.
Blazing Transfer Students: Season 1
If Fate/Apocrypha doesn't sate your anime
appetite, tune in to Season 1 of Blazing Transfer
Students.
While it's not anime--it's a live-action sequel
to the manga of the same name--Blazing Transfer
Students promises to offer up plenty of anime
style, with a premise so ridiculous we won't
be able to not watch it: seven boys, all named
Kakeru, get transferred to a new school at
the same time on a secret mission.
That's either the worst or the best thing
we've ever heard, and we'll find out for sure
when the series hits Netflix on November 10th.
Lady Dynamite: Season 2
There's always something unexpected in each
episode of Netflix's hit comedy Lady Dynamite,
and fans can now look forward to a brand new
season.
Maria Bamford returns as, well, herself to
headline eight new episodes alongside cast
regular Fred Melamed.
Both Bamford and Netflix have remained tight-lipped
about what the new season will entail, but
if it's anything like Season 1, we can expect
plenty of Bamford's signature humor.
"I do feel better now that I'm off my meds.
I feel SUPER-charged.
Tune in on November 10th.
DeRay Davis: How To Act Black
Stand-up comedian DeRay Davis lands on Netflix
this November with How to Act Black, a new
comedy special pulled straight from Davis'
stand-up routines.
According to Netflix, the special will dive
into life and show business from Davis' point
of view, promising a knock-out series of punchlines
and anecdotes than any comedy fan is sure
to love.
Take a look on November 14th.
The Punisher: Season 1
From the minute he was introduced in Season
2 of Daredevil, fans have been eagerly awaiting
Frank Castle's solo Netflix outing, and the
wait is finally over.
Jon Bernthal returns as the skull-shirted
anti-hero on November 17th.
Season 1 of The Punisher will be comprised
of 13 episodes, and Daredevil's Deborah Ann
Woll co-stars, although there's no hint whether
Daredevil himself will make an appearance--or
any of the other Defenders, for that matter.
Jim & Andy: The Great Beyond
In 1999's Man on the Moon, Jim Carrey turned
in a powerful performance as comedian Andy
Kaufman.
And as the documentary Jim & Andy: The Great
Beyond reveals, Carrey went to insane lengths
for the role.
Literally, psychotic lengths.
The documentary is composed mainly of behind
the scenes footage from the set of Man on
the Moon.
In character every step of the way, Carrey
would torment the director, provoke his co-stars,
and, basically, "Kaufman" the hell out of
the entire production.
"Universal didn't want the footage we took
behind the scenes to surface so people wouldn't
think I was an ---hole."
Even off the set, Carrey enmeshed himself
in Kaufman, once spending two hours on the
phone with director Ron Howard to talk about
their upcoming film How the Grinch Stole Christmas…
in character as Andy Kaufman.
It may have worked wonders for Man on the
Moon, but at the same time, it probably explains
just as much about the mess that was Grinch.
You can see the craziness for yourself when
Jim and Andy debuts November 17.
Longmire: Season 6
Saddle up, because Netflix's critically acclaimed
crime drama Longmire is galloping into its
sixth and final season on November 17th.
If we can believe the trailer, this looks
like the end of the road for series protagonist
Walt Longmire, who's ready to turn in his
badge and give up his life as a lawman.
Netflix grabbed this modern-day Western when
A&E pulled the plug after three seasons, making
this Longmire's third season under the Netflix
umbrella.
Mudbound
This Netflix original centers on two soldiers
at the end of World War II who return home
to rural Mississippi, only to find that, in
many ways, their struggles are only just beginning.
Mudbound premiered at the Sundance Film Festival
in 2017 to critical acclaim, and Netflix picked
it up for distribution.
Sitting tight with an exceptional percent
rating on Rotten Tomatoes, Mudbound definitely
looks like a film worth waiting for.
Check it out on November 17th.
Brian Regan: Nunchucks and Flamethrowers
With his sarcastic delivery and laid back
comedic style, Brian Regan has been making
audiences laugh for decades now, and he's
back with a new stand-up special coming exclusively
to Netflix.
Nunchucks and Flamethrowers promises all new
jokes and more of Regan's on-point commentary
on everyday life.
Check it out on November 21st.
Saving Capitalism
This movie began life as a Kickstarter campaign
that ultimately raised nearly $300,000 for
the film's production.
The documentary follows Robert Reich as he
travels the nation to speak to Americans about
the state of the country and how people with
different political views can find a common
ground.
Saving Capitalism should offer an interesting
glimpse into the political climate of the
US.
Look for it on Netflix on November 21st.
Godless
Are Westerns making their big comeback?
It sure seems like it, and Netflix's upcoming
Godless is the latest outlaw joining the gang.
Starring Jeff Daniels, Godless tells the story
of Frank Griffin, a bandit hellbent on getting
revenge against his ex-partner.
The six-part miniseries was created by Scott
Frank, who penned Logan, with Steven Soderbergh
serving as executive producer.
Get set for all the slick six-shooter action
on November 22nd.
She's Gotta Have It: Season 1
Spike Lee's 1986 romantic comedy She's Gotta
Have It wasn't a smash hit by any means, but
it brought in over $7 million on a $175,000
budget, so you could definitely call it a
financial success.
And apparently the honchos at Netflix thought
it wouldn't be a terrible idea to capitalize
on that by turning it into a series...even
if it happened 21 years later.
The show will follow the same premise as the
film: one woman has three lovers, but hesitates
to settle down with any of them.
Will it capture the same magic as Lee's original
film?
We'll all have the chance to find out when
Season 1 premieres on November 23rd.
Cuba and the Cameraman
After making waves at the Venice International
Film Festival, Jon Alpert's Cuba and the Cameraman
is set to come out on Netflix on November
24th.
The documentary chronicles four decades of
revolution, war, and Communism in Cuba under
the rule of Fidel Castro.
It's not light viewing, but Cuba and the Cameraman
should go on everyone's list of must-see documentaries.
Frontier: Season 2
Jason Momoa's gritty period drama is getting
a return with Season 2, launching viewers
back into the blood-soaked action and frontier
justice.
Created by Rob and Peter Blackie, Frontier
follows Momoa's character Declan Harp and
his fight against fur traders in Eastern Canada.
Critics have given the show mixed reviews,
with some praising the action and the set
pieces and others deriding Frontier's inconsistent
pacing.
However, if you're looking for something action-packed
to watch while you kick back and relax, you
can catch Frontier Season 2 on November 24th.
Trailer Park Boys: Out of the Park: USA
In the first installment of the Trailer Park
Boys' semi-spinoff show Out of the Park, Bubbles,
Julian, and Ricky went to Europe to spread
their shenanigans abroad.
In the second season, they're heading to the
States.
Some fans felt Out of the Park just wasn't
as good as the show, so fingers crossed the
second season will bring back that old trailer
park magic.
"It's Samsquanch, Ricky, and there's one right
outside my f---ing door, right now, he's trying
to get in my shed."
"Holy s---, Bubbles, I see him.
Don't scare him, he's f---ing worth a lot
of money."
Look for Out of the Park: USA on November
24.
Glitch: Season 2
There have been several different series about
people mysteriously coming back to life in
recent years.
From the French Les Revenants to the American
remake, The Returned, and ABC's unrelated
Resurrection, this idea somehow became the
most remade trope in recent memory.
And the Australian telling of the story, Glitch,
is built on the same bones: citizens of a
small town have to come to grips with the
fact that their loved ones are returning from
the grave.
But while the American series fell a little
flat, Glitch was much better received and
went on to win several Australian television
awards.
Netflix came in to co-produce Season 2, which
airs internationally November 28th.
Good Morning Call: Season 2
Based on a manga of the same name, Good Morning
Call is a romantic comedy series about a girl
who accidentally becomes roommates with the
hottest boy in school.
Japanese shenanigans ensue, leading to plenty
of ridiculous situations and a few unexpected
friendships.
Season 2 is set to land on Netflix on November
28th, so keep your eyes peeled.
That covers all the Netflix originals.
Now let's take a look at some of the new movies
Netflix is adding to its lineup in November.
New movies
To start with, Netflix is adding a handful
of new action movies this month.
On the 1st, look for Chappie, a sci-fi action
comedy from District 9's Neil Blomkamp, as
well as Men in Black.
"Now that's what I'm talking about."
November 1st is also seeing the addition of
some classic comedies like the original Scary
Movie and The Whole Nine Yards.
For a more serious watch, be sure to check
out brand new documentaries like 2016's It's
Not Yet Dark, an inspiring story about Irish
filmmaker Simon Fitzmaurice, who set out to
direct a film after he was diagnosed with
neurodegenerative ALS at the age of 34.
Look for it November 2.
Other documentaries to watch for this month
include 2017's Williams, a supercharged glimpse
into the founder of the Williams Formula 1
team, and Long Time Running, a music-driven
glimpse into Canadian rock band The Tragically
Hip.
Netflix's drama lineup is similarly getting
better in November, with 42, Field of Dreams,
Michael Clayton, and The Pursuit of Happyness
all arriving on the first of the month.
Those are some hard-hitting films, but don't
worry: Netflix is adding plenty of films for
family time, too, with Casper and Charlotte's
Web hitting the service on November 1st, Scooby-Doo
2: Monsters Unleashed on November 13, and
The Boss Baby on November 22nd.
Then, once the kids are in bed, keep the post-Halloween
chills going with Silent Hill and Oculus on
November 1st and 2017's Darkness Rising on
the 27th.
But horror shouldn't be too serious, so you
can also look forward to the campy scares
of 2010's Piranha 3D on November 20.
New television
If the first of the month comes and you've
finished binging on Stranger Things already,
don't freak out.
There are plenty of other shows to grab your
undivided attention.
In addition to The Punisher, Netflix is bringing
on Season 1 of Stranger, a South Korean mystery
thriller about a police prosecutor on the
hunt for a serial killer.
The series garnered rave reviews in its home
country, and you can experience all the twists
and turns on November 1st.
Also, get ready for police-on-convict action,
COPS style, with Under Arrest: Season 7 dropping
on the first of the month and Lockup: State
Prisons arriving on the 15th.
Finally, settle in for the third season of
Broadchurch on November 27th, the critically
acclaimed British drama that was nominated
for seven BAFTA awards in its first season,
and which Entertainment Weekly went so far
as to call "a bona fide national obsession."
"Now that's impressive."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!